un but pas vu paranormal juste pouvoir
les chiffrer ce qu'on a vu l'âme d'un
mort passé sur une chaîne d'information
c'était juste après un accident en
espagne une chaîne info filmé la scène
vous allez voir l'âme d'une personne qui
passe devant la caméra se regarde
[Musique]
merci bonsoir bonsoir à tour alors
qu'est jocelyne keller jocelyne alors
vous êtes spécialiste vous avez écrit
plein de bouquins est ce que c'est
possible de voir si l'âme d'un mort
comme ça est ce que c'est concrètement
non non d'accord donc ça c'est quoi
alors c'est truqué c'est quoi non c'est
pas forcément truc et ça peut être ça
peut être un insecte qui passe devant la
caméra
ça peut être mais je le vois qui se fait
pas chez eux ça peut être heureusement
vers le bas est ce qu'on a vu un
magicien bat le record du monde de ce
spectacle en lévitation le plus rapide
du monde
le gars des cités dans american d'autres
talents c'est chic
[Musique]
ça ses portes à la normale holtz et
jaune j'en ai d'autres comme ça on a un
hack est avec nous ça va bien à un vin
très bien être avec nous vous habitez en
région parisienne et s'étend méditons
que j'ai fait une rencontre incroyable
vous avez fait la connaissance
d'extraterrestres ya ghost dans un
instant sur ces 8 et vous avez tout nous
raconter
vous avez rencontré des extraterrestres
déjà eu comment comment s'est passé
c'est chez vous ils sont arrivés chez
nous alors déjà cédé années de travail
ah oui dans la méditation parce que ce à
travers la méditation et j'ai atteint
celui aujourd'hui qui fait que quand je
médite il ya une méditation qui se fait
planétairement wells et ça l'a bien sûr
tout se dit on est beaucoup à la faire
en même temps la même heure chaque jour
pour la planète d'accord et vous voyez
et j'ai atteint un seuil où maintenant
il ya une seule méditation que je fais
où je pars c'est à dire que mon énergie
je pars je vole un peu où je veux votre
corps à ce rush voilà et je me retrouve
soit dans l'espace soit en antarctique
pour finir ma maison avec gratuit ça
augure bien des gens d'apprécier non
mais alors combien d'années il ya des
gens qui comptent pas moi je sais ce que
je suis d'accord mais et paris sont
venus vous voir en bas de chez vous les
extraterrestres 1
c'était très l'état j'ai dit est ce que
tu m'as temps où il y avait un
extraterrestre en bas de chez vous en
faites ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il ya
eu un moment j'ai dit bon c'est sympa de
vous voir comme ça à travers les
méditations et passe à la maison
j'aimerais bien vous voir en vrai quoi
est en fait un soir je suis descendu
chez moi sortir mon chien ouais et ma
rue où j'habite et complètement blindés
constamment c'est à dire la rue
oberkampf bâtir avec tous les bars les
machins s'il n'y avait pas un chat dans
la rue ouais et 11 heures du soir les
bistrots sont toujours pas un hasard si
elle courait et juste à l'angle où je
l'emmène un parc avec personne et je me
retourne il ya un mec qui était là mais
un peu space vraiment jean michel
labrousse
un peu comme les noms restent grands
cheveux
blanc il avait quelque chose de votre
chien qui tenait par une corde
non mais je présente pas et en fait je
vois et j'ai été happé par cette
personne et je lui dit bonsoir il y
avait quelque chose de très spécial en
cuir et il me regarde qui marchait pas
on n'aime pas les humains ah oui là j'ai
compris que mon appel avait été entendue
dans et donc j'ai parlé deux minutes
avec lui un moment je meurs tout pour
rattraper mon chien et puis là quand le
chef des menaces contenant les gardiens
ap gardiens ni la myriade de vie la
pléiade et non mais vous l'avez revu
depuis
non mais vous avez revu doté que ça
terrestre nom est mêlé je communique
différemment par l accord il y en a ici
là sur le plateau non par là on pense à
rien voilà la lourdeur la lourdeur la
lourdeur non on va voir on va voir
l'histoire
votre histoire dans un instant aussi
vous c'est une histoire complètement fou
vol 1 michel vous avez eu un accident
qui va changer votre vie à tout jamais
vous allez nous raconter ça mais pour le
moment est ce qu'on a vu un homme se
faire attaquer par un esprit dans les
couloirs de son immeuble
ah oui et vous allez nous dire si ça
peut être vrai ou faux regardez c'est
une caméra de surveillance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or il faut savoir cette vidéo elle
circule sur le web depuis des années
elle est classée dans les très très
douteuse d'accord très très douteuse
ouais c'est une mise en scène voilà ça
c'est une mise en scène est ce qu'on a
vu jean vincent placé dire à un alien
pour n'est pas sur ta planète a
travaillé chez toi tu vas voir
est ce qu'on a vu le fantôme d'un enfant
traverser un cimetière alors ça ça a été
vu dans les 30 histoires mystérieuses
les nous dira si c'est vrai au pot
roslan regarder ça alors qu'il se
promène dans un cimetière
un adolescent film ce qui est peut-être
l'une des vidéos de fantômes les plus
troublantes que l'on n'ait jamais vu une
silhouette enfantine semble courir entre
les tombes puis bondir en haut d'un
arbre avant de s'évanouir
mystérieusement
j'étais sous le choc je ne savais pas
quoi penser
alors c'est ce que c'est vrai ou pas
très difficile à dire parce que l'on
connaît pas la personne et la vidéo on
sait pas dans quelles circonstances est
quand même très très flou possible mais
je peux absolument pas attester que c
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est vrai
d'accord alors on à michel qui avec no
mercy michel d'être là vous êtes soliste
au sein de prestigieuses compagnies
chorégraphiques latry subd théâtre
ballet de toulouse vous étiez sportive
et votre corps était votre métier avant
votre terrible accident et michel vous
avez un terrible accident de voiture le
3 novembre 1989 à la suite de cet
accident vous perdez connaissance et
vous êtes plongé dans le coma
à ce moment-là précis vous expliquerez
sortir de votre corps qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement ce que vous
pouvez nous décrire ce qui s'est passé
alors sortir du corps c'était une
manière c'est une manière de le dire
c'est une projection mon avis et c'est
surtout que je suis parti une vitesse
vertigineuse par une double spirale
d'accord ça c'est intéressant pourquoi
parce que moi ça me rappelle la dn déjà
c'est comme si l'adn parler d'elle même
se projeter et vraiment c'est une sortie
du corps la plus belle des choses c'est
que ça se passe au travers de couleurs
et de musique
non mais qu'est ce que vous avez vu au
fait qu'est ce que vous avez vu vous
avez quoi concrètement les lumières
allumées les meilleurs souvenirs pas on
n'est pas à pour arriver dans la lumière
je me suis passé par cette double
spirale
à une vitesse vertigineuse d'intérêt
surtout c'est que la transformation au
niveau vibrations des couleurs et des
sens et est absolument extraordinaire on
arrivé à une notion de beauté de que
soit de la couleur quand et du son que
l'on ne connaît pas ici ça c'est quelque
chose de sublime et j'ai été déposés
dans un océan de lumière je le traduis
comme ça parce que bon il faut en parler
o transmettre un petit peu l'expérience
n'en fait on peut pas décrire d'accord
et après vous être revenu à la vie pas
du tout non est restée là-bas que
maintenant j'ai vu une personne
magnifique qui flottait habillant en
mauve avec nos bouquets de viry salamin
qui ressemblait à ma grand-mère à
winnezeele flotter et je ne suis revenu
vous allez vite là parce que cette
lumière en réalité elle nous infuse de
la connaissance
d'accord on a l'impression d'avoir toute
la connaissance du monde qui
s'infiltrent dans nous et ce n'est pas
qu'une impression on a l'impression
d'avoir tout est également on a le
sentiment d'être enveloppé par un amour
de ce que j'ai connu l'amour une passion
de 51 ans
donc quelque chose de dense devrait de
beaux et bien c'est une maquette à côté
de ce que l'on ressent à ce moment là
d'accord mais valérie cette expérience
de mort imminente qu'on appelle la mire
des expériences il ya beaucoup de
scientifiques qui se penchent dessus
parce que c'est pas un cas isolé votre
votre histoire et le sujet l'ip labro
qu'on connaît bien vécu cette histoire
est racontée dans un livre
oui en disant que lui aussi avait connu
cette histoire de l'histoire que michel
exactement ces sortes de tontons mais
enfin le voilà il était tombé malade le
coma etc et il avait vu cette sauce est
une aile blanc et ensuite ils te décrire
ce qui s'est passé autour de lui peut
raconter comment étaient les chirurgiens
va alors qu'est ce qu'il racontait qu
est-ce qui et comment il était habillé
pu revenir
c'est assez étonnant et c'est une
expérience très difficile à appréhender
moi j'écoute et madame et je pense qu'il
faut tous les gens qui ont des
témoignages comme ça il faut les écouter
avec bienveillance
parce que on se sent tellement ça va
profiter le mandant loin chez nous
personnellement qu'on a du mal à écouter
ce témoignage alors qu'ils croyaient
maxi bien sûr il ya chaque année il ya
des centaines d' expérience de mort
imminente
j'ai la mère d'un ami qui a vécu un
accouchement difficile elle est partie
dans le coma elle s'est vue elle s'est
vue dans le lit elle a vu son corps elle
a vu tous les détails des gâteaux loin
de tout l'hôpital avec même un petit
papier été créés s'est coincé derrière
cacher derrière le lait personne ne
pouvait le voir elle est finalement
revenue dans la matière de manière un
peu compliqué parce qu'elle était très
bien là où elle était et elle a dit aux
médecins tiens j'ai vu il ya un papier
avec marc et sa cacher derrière le lit
mais non madame ya absolument rien le
mec a été le docteur a été regardé
derrière le lit elle a trouvé ce morceau
avec écrit exactement ce qui était
indiqué ebongue mais c'est vrai parce
que je l' ai vécu deux fois 1 à 13 ans
quand il avait fait une tentative de
suicide je suis parti dans le coma je me
suis vue sur la table en animation de
style je suis parti dans la lumière
la deuxième fois c'était en 2001 et
j'étais dans cet endroit qui est en fait
sans limite blanc comme dit madame etc
que de l'amour est en fait quand on
allait d'ailleurs la ville rose on n'a
pas envie de revenir parce que c'est
c'est indescriptible comme dit cette
dame là et en fait c'est choquant à m'en
passer celui de revenir à l'indien que
c'est difficile quand on est bon on en
rigole mais c'est vrai que c'est là oui
c'est vrai quand même le monde
tout le monde parle de la même chose
donc c'est assez pendant alors ce qu'on
avait un avaleur de sabres perdre sa
crédibilité en deux secondes
oui regardez c'est au début c'est très
impressionnant et à la fin le gars se
sont un peu mal à l'aise regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à
alors alors oui oui mais quand on parle
souvent de cette douceur de l'au-delà
couvrir est connu que je vous crois tout
à fait serge lama lé chanteur a vécu ça
aussi la très bien raconté aussi dans un
livre souvent on peut certains disent
que c'est parce qu'on a peur de la mort
et qu'on veut se rassurer en se disant
que c'est plus doux que c'est plus beau
que quand on est mieux là où tu vas pas
vraiment madame en vain une délivrance
n'est pas une question
pas du tout ge a perdu tous de mourir
alors j'aurais parlé michèle échelle
vous qui avez connu ça quand vous êtes
revenu à la vie est ce que vous étiez
déçu ou non mais ce coup là voilà déjà
j'ai vécu pourrons pour venir
je me suis vu dans la voiture
effectivement ce qui est rapporté au
niveau des blocs un dico c'est moi j'ai
vu comme de radio vous voyez exactement
et j'ai vu que j'avais le rachis brisé
et que j'étais hors paradi's été
rappelés donc ça c'est une réalité
quant à ce que vous venez de dire où
c'est une explication opérationnel dans
le rationnel il ya deux explications
il ya deux voies partout - et celle du
milieu c'est la meilleure
on s'en fait 3 mais ce genre
d'expérience quand on arrive dans cette
lumière c'est une infusion réel de
connaissances on a l'impression qu'on
est saisie dans la connaissance mais
vraiment qui dépasse la terre et quand
on revient on me poser la question sur
le retour le retour oui moi je me suis
retrouvé tétraplégique d'accord
l'intérêt ça a été la transformation du
personnage derrière la transformation
qui s'est faite par un moment donné au
bout de deux ans ce serait quand même
deux ans un tétraplégique
j'ai une envie de pétrir du pain j'ai
fait du pain pendant deux mois denis
boulangère même source
j'aimerais beaucoup dans les séries
c'est fou d'elle même est énorme et le
désir de pétrir c'était quoi parce que
la relation à la réalité après qu'on l'a
retrouvé
c'était ce que soulever cette cette dame
la rue là on n'est pas dans la réalité
on est dans l'irrationnel
oui pour la personne qui est ici en
réalité c'est une de mes produits pour
vous dépêtrer du champ des boulettes
[Applaudissements]